le pass sanitaire s'invitera t-il en
discothèque ou sera-t-il refoulé à
l'entrée
le sujet fait en tout cas débats dans la
profession fermé depuis 15 mois
certaines boîtes de nuit le réclame pour
permettre une réouverture plus rapide
d'autres en revanche refuse l'idée
d'imposer des tests qu'ovide négatifs
comme critère d'entrée
c'est le cas de nicolas brouant patron
du new vegas est la croix en touraine
qu'a rencontré samuel colin on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
mal à revenir ma femme arrive pas et
venir sans avoir les et larmes qui
coulent le retour sur place est toujours
difficile pour son propriétaire
c'est le 14e mois sans client ici la
boîte de nuit est à l'arrêt depuis mars
2020 et le premier confinement pour
autant il s'oppose à une réouverture
grâce à un pass sanitaire qui pourrait
passer par des tests salivaires à
l'entrée comment fait-on en campagne
pour laisser des gens dehors pendant un
quart d'heure attendre le résultat du
test gérer l'énervement à celui qu'on va
dire bah non désolé tu est positif et au
groupe de copains qui sera venu à côté
etc
on va se retaper des responsabilités nos
mères vont nous dire attention le bordel
dans la rue les voisins se plaignent
ceux ci cela et on va encore chauffer un
truc en plus donc un moment ou un autre
faut juste être conscient la crainte de
devoir gérer de nouveaux débordements et
d'être tenu pour responsable des cas du
coc vite 10,9 dans leur établissement en
touraine et dans les petites villes de
france il serait une majorité à partager
cet avis car l inverse des grands clubs
avec de célèbres tête d'affiche les
sorties sont plus impulsive bout d'un
moment les clients c'est pareil vous
revenir une fois deux fois trois fois
puis si on n'y retrouve plus l'ambiance
si on ne trouve pas le truc parce qu'il
ya un atmosphère et qu'il ya trop
l'impression et parise iront dans la rue
dans les bars qui sont en train de faire
en ce moment de toute façon attendre
avant de rouvrir les discothèques
le gouvernement semble suivre cette voie
le projet de loi qui prévoit un pass
annie terre le réserve aux événements de
plus de 1000 personnes
il doit être adopté par le parlement le
27 mai prochain